hello welcome back to the white void so
again I am NOT here to entertain you
today I am here because I am feeling
really great right now about myself and
my life and my plans and I want to talk
to you about it so the thing about
people is that eventually they grow up
and at least what I found is that if you
like someone the way that they are
watching them go through that change can
be a bit weird and uncomfortable but at
the same time it's inevitable people do
change but I think if you try and ignore
that fact then you're gonna find
yourself pretty unhappy which i think is
basically what ended up happening to me
I am NOT that cute little british boy
making youtube videos in his bedroom
anymore I have a mortgage I pay taxes I
have an accountant I go to work in an
office I have a full-time job I mean
this is a bit of a weird one but it's
still there you know I wouldn't consider
myself an adult really but I'm clearly
not a kid either
and honestly now that I can finally
admit that to myself I feel like this
massive weight has been lifted off my
chest like last year for me I think was
sort of an exercise in me trying to
mimic my younger self because that's
what I thought people wanted to see but
it's not what I won't do because that's
not the person that I am anymore the
time has finally come I think for me to
make stuff that really reflects how I
feel I've changed and I've been trying
to make that transition a bit already
sort of in small ways but to really push
myself I've come up with this slightly
mad plan to take me through the rest of
the year one that I am both very excited
and more than a little bit nervous about
you may remember once upon a time I said
I was working on a screenplay for a
short film which now I still haven't
finished but narrative filmmaking is
still something I really want to have a
proper gala it's the thing I get most
excited about what I'm working on
anything at the moment and so what I'm
gonna do is instead of making a short
film I am gonna make five of them one
every two months for the rest of the
year starting in April to go with those
I also want to make a behind-the-scenes
video for each of the shorts and you
know I want to continue to make whatever
I want to make as well your regular
YouTube content what you've come to
expect from me on this channel that is
not going to stop although it may be a
bit more mature or more immature I
haven't really decided yet but basically
you will see something from me every one
or two weeks and that is a commitment
that I have made publicly so that's good
my goal of all of this ultimately is
just to
connect with you in the best way that I
possibly can by doing and making the
things that make me happy and sharing
them with you you know I want to
challenge your expectations of what it
is do you expect from me and I mean
really what I want to do is stop talking
about it and show you that I'm serious
about this by just doing it so just
before I go I do want to say thank you
so much for sticking with me through
this I'm scared phase of mine it really
really does mean a lot and I guess I
just want to ask you to get excited to
see something new from me because I'm
really excited to make something new for
you it's gonna be great my body is ready
for the short-films good and on that now
goodbye you've just had the almost
imponderable joy of watching Charlie is
so cool like which makes you like cool
[Music]
I'm very excited to be filming this
video and it's over now but I don't want
to stop so I should really stop this
okay goodbye